wie es weitergeht wir haben also heute
erst mal zweimal hohen besuch gehabt
also heute mittag hatten wir eine
expertenrunde nehme ich das mal mit dem
gesundheitsminister wo wir mit
vertretern der niedergelassenen ärzte
hauptkammer auf hausärzte bzw
alle drei im krankenhaus vertretenden
alle drei im kreis vertreten in
krankenhäusern über die
leistungsfähigkeit des
gesundheitssystems ziel gesprochen haben
und über die möglichkeiten diese
leistungsfähigkeit noch dadurch zu
stärken dass wir die krankenhäuser und
niedergelassene ärzte mit zusätzlichem
personal und mit denke ich mal auch
nötigen verbrauchsmaterialien den
mundschutz und dergleichen nach
ausstatten
die problematik der mundschutz geht bei
ihnen ja rauf und runter durch die
medien aber wir sind da guter dinge dass
wir da vom land auch tatkräftig
unterstützt werden was für die
krankenhäuser und auch für ihn entlassen
ärzte sehr wichtig war es informationen
wir haben uns auch darauf verständigt
sehr pragmatisch an die situation hand
zu gehen weil natürlich auch die frage
nehmen wir beispielsweise ärztliches
personal oder pflegepersonal in
quarantäne auf die auf den verdacht hin
dass die mit einer kontaktperson mit
einer mittelbaren kontaktperson in
kontakt gekommen sein könnten
damit würden wir de facto sie haben
vielleicht mitbekommen dass wir
mittlerweile wenn wir die wege der
infektion hier im kreis heinsberg
verfolgen sagen da es mittlerweile so
viele querverbindung und so viele
mögliche infektionsquellen dass es auch
gar keinen sinn macht jetzt da weiter
groß im großen stil nach möglichen
kontaktpersonen zu suchen wir haben also
für uns entschieden bei einer steigenden
anzahl von infizierten besprechen zur
zeit von 35 jetzt das augenmerk darauf
zu richten wie stellen wir die
leistungsfähigkeit des
gesundheitssystems hier im kreis
heinsberg sicher wie stellen wir sicher
dass leute die tatsächlich erkrankt sind
schnellstmöglich über ein
leistungsfähiges haus als system eine
erstuntersuchung erfahren und dann auch
vom haus als erfahren wie sieht der
krankheitsverlauf voraussichtlich aus
ist das eine sache die ich wirklich zu
hause auskurieren kann und vielleicht
eine information bei den 35 sind bisher
nur die ersten zwei über die ja auch
groß berichtet war das ehepaar wirklich
in stationäre behandlung die restlichen
da ist der krankheitsverlauf so milde
dass man wirklich
von ausgehen kann die kommen mit einer
häufigen behandlung klar da mal eben auf
meiner liste schaue ich noch nicht
vergessen habe erfreulich ist dass auch
das umfeld des gangelter ehepaares also
auch die kinder und die anverwandten
alle negativ getestet sind das heißt
also auch im häuslichen bereich ist
nicht zwangsläufig so dass man über eine
zwangsweise ansteckung nachdenken muss
was die untersuchung den kindergärten
angeht da kriegen heute abend die
ergebnisse heute geistert auch ein
bisschen die meldung durch die gazetten
wir würden über sperrbezirke nachdenken
und hätten schon sperrbezirk
eingerichtet das war ein
kommunikationsproblem zwischen den
kollegen benkert und mir auch da soll
man sagen in der ganzen hektik die wir
zurzeit haben passieren solche sachen
aber ich denke dass in form als genug
das aufzuklären und ich hoffe wenn ich
hier mal einen fehler machen dass sie
dann auch mit mir so umgehen ja ich
denke mal wir sind alle im moment etwas
angespannt der ministerpräsident war
heute hier hat meinen mitarbeitern für
die arbeit gedankt hat sich von der
arbeit des krisenstabes überzeugt und
ich denke das war für die mitarbeitern
wirkliche anerkennung auch eine
wirkliche motivation für die arbeit die
sie hier in den letzten tagen leisten
die arbeiten alle bis zum anschlag
wir haben aber auch mitgeteilt bekommen
dass man unsere arbeit auf landesebene
auch als fachlich richtig und als
kompetent einschätzen auch das ist ein
wichtiges feedback in so einer situation
und ich muss wirklich sagen was gut tut
in dieser situation ist das wirklich
auch die kommunikationskanäle mit dem
land funktionieren das heißt also die
behörden ziehen kommunikationsmedien
aber organisatorisch an einem strang und
ich bin wirklich guter dinge dass wir
vom land auch noch unterstützung
erfahren werde nirgendwo sind wir hier
im kreis heinsberg schon denke ich mal
ein bisschen die blaupause dafür wie
auch andere landkreise und vielleicht
auch ganz deutschland mit der geschichte
umgeht denn es ist ja wirklich so dass
man das sagen auch fachleute davon
ausgehen muss dass sich das schon über
das ganze land ausbreiten wird also ich
will jetzt nicht der begriff epidemie
ist ist immer so ein schwieriger begriff
auf nation über nationaler ebene spricht
man von einer pandemie
ich bin kein mit
ich muss nur sagen es wird denke ich mal
für deutschland schon eine
ernstzunehmende situation dass wir die
im kreis heinsberg jetzt schon länger
haben das haben sie alle mitgekriegt
aber ich bin auch guter dinge dass wir
vor allen dingen wenn man transparent
mit der bevölkerung umgeht und wenn man
den auch zeitnah erklärt was man vorhat
und wie man gedenkt vorzugehen die auch
dazu bewegen kann ruhe zu bewahren denn
ich glaube und das ist ja schon zigmal
gesagt worden wir bewegen uns hier auch
auf dem schmalen grat zwischen ernst
nehmen auf der einen seite und umkippen
in eine panik auf der anderen seite ich
denke da haben wir alle nicht nur die
politisch verantwortlichen sondern auch
die medien auch sie in hohe
verantwortung dafür dass wir da sachlich
und fair miteinander umgehen und gut
berichten
aber ich mein eindruck ist also von dem
was ich jetzt sehr mit ihnen auch erlebt
habe dass wir das gemeinsam hinkriegen
ich danke ihnen für ihre aufmerksamkeit
bisher nach denen nachdem man muss ganz
klipp und klar sagen wenn man die
empfehlungen des robert koch instituts
rki heißt es immer strenggenommen nimmt
dann muss man sagen wenn einer ohne
entsprechenden schutz mit einem
infizierten in kontakt war gehört er
schon zur risikogruppe 1 das heißt er
müsste eigentlich 14 tage lang in
quarantäne gehen so jetzt können sie
sich vorstellen das ist ja im fall des
krankenhauses erklärte aber dass er mal
den praktischen auswirkungen gesehen
dann waren direkt zwölf menschen die
dringend benötigt werden in so einem
krankenhaus nicht mehr zur verfügung die
sind an 14 tage aus dem verkehr gezogen
wenn wir das so in dieser form
durchhalten können sich vorstellen wie
schnell wir dann mit möglichen
kapazitäten am ende sind deswegen war es
auch heute eine wichtige aufgabe mit dem
minister wirklich mal abzuklären wie
gehen wir mit solchen leuten um dann
möchte ich jetzt noch ganze detail gehen
aber wir werden dann pragmatischen weg
finden müssen uns nicht selber sozusagen
unser eigenes gesundheitssystem
lahmzulegen
beispiel war ein oberarzt der überhaupt
keiner der krankheitssymptome zeigt wenn
man aber jetzt eigentlich aus dem
verkehr ziehen müsste da haben wir
natürlich auch erstmals auch das
verwiesen was jetzt sachstand ist aber
ich denke dass auch das ist eine aufgabe
für uns alle mit den oberen behörden
zusammen da in den nächsten tagen
löschen modus vivendi zu finden nein
also wir haben in unserem krisenstab
auch ich persönlich auch schon in dem
ersten aufschlag mit dem minister auch
in der ersten pressekonferenz wenn sich
vielleicht erinnern schon gesagt also
für uns ist die häusliche quarantäne
dass das mittel der wahl
es ist natürlich so in so einem
informations hin und her habe ich auch
äußerungen beispielsweise von einem
bürgermeister gehört dann sagte da muss
man vielleicht mal drüber nachdenken so
ich denke man muss immer sehr gut
abschätzen was sind die
informationsquellen deswegen bemühe ich
mich auch beispielsweise über social
media auch informationen aus erster hand
zu bieten ich kann mir sehr über die
ihre berichterstattung überhaupt nichts
nicht klagen das ist wirklich sehr
objektiv und sehr sachlich aber man muss
dann auch immer wieder gucken wir müssen
nicht in den bereich von spekulationen
reinkommen denn ich denke mal wir müssen
uns alle gemeinsam damit unterstützen
es ist eine aufgabe die alle betrifft
die letztendlich auch sie als
journalisten betrifft auch sie in ihrem
persönlichen umfeld ich glaube das ist
eine krise die wir alle gemeinsam in
deutschland meist dann müssen da steht
nicht die politik auf der einen seite
die bevölkerung auf der anderen und die
medien stehen
oder zwischen sondern ich denke mal wir
sitzen auch in der situation alle malen
ein boot sie sollen objektiv berichten
dass auch ganz wichtig das muss auch
vertrauens sein das muss auch objektiv
sein aber wir müssen aufpassen denke ich
mal das so bei schwierigen situationen
und die werden kommen da bin ich auch
schon überzeugt ja also dass wir da die
dinge nicht auch zum schutz unserer
völker zum schuss aber von uns allen aus
dem ruder laufen
also wir haben den krankenhäusern
gesprochen die haben die üblichen
intensiv kapazitäten sind aber in der
lage
da haben sich in den letzten tagen schon
darauf eingerichtet durch maßnahmen wie
wir kann entlassen werden wir müssen
jetzt nur aufnehmen was kann man
verschieben
bestimmte abteilungen auch für die
intensivpflege freizumachen
ich bin da ist nicht mitzahlen
spekulieren aber ich gehe davon aus dass
wir das nach dem jetzigen stand der
dinge wenn auch das personal den
charakter erhalten bleibt wir in der
lage sind auch im kreis heinsberg
eine gerettete anzahl von wirklich
schwer erkranken angemessen zu behandeln
also wir haben da muss man auch ganz
offen sagen darüber nachgedacht bis zum
ende der woche zuzulassen
wobei wir das natürlich ich habe ja mal
gesagt die lage ist immer dynamisch
jetzt noch nicht abschließend beurteilen
können aber vielleicht mal als
ankündigung ist spricht im moment mehr
dafür die vier tage noch zuzulassen weil
wir auch wenn wir jetzt am dienstag die
alle plätze schule kommen lassen würden
auch mit einem vielzahl von fragen der
schulleiter konfrontiert sind vom schutz
von desinfektion über was mache ich mit
kindern die krankheitssymptome haben was
ist mit dem lehrerkollegium also da muss
man vielleicht dann auch wirklich mal
abwägen
auf der einen seite macht mit sicherheit
es sind nicht zu viele soziale kontakte
auf einem engen raum zusammen zu bringen
auf der anderen seite ist natürlich auch
und das weiß ich aus vielen feedback was
ich auch bekommen dass wir viele
familien natürlich eine sehr schwierige
situation
wir haben heute oft ganztagsbetreuung
nicht nur im kindergarten sondern auch
in der schule ja ich hab selber 665 zu
hause sitzen
ich weiß selber dass erster hand was das
bedeutet wenn man dann die sprösslinge
zu hause hat und seien sie noch so fit
wie dell
aber das bringt berufliche probleme
damit mit dem arbeitgeber wir haben uns
auch bemüht jetzt mal musterschreiben
den arbeitgeber zu machen
und also auch da dritten kommt ist auch
meine mannschaft ein ganzer wust von
fragen zu die die wir auch versuchen
werden zu beantworten wir müssen
wirklich prioritäten setzen und ich
haben die sicherstellung des
gesundheitswesens hat für uns ist im
moment oberste priorität
[Musik]
also ich meine wir haben mittlerweile
wir sind schon was manche dinge angeht
auch online erreichbaren da wir bauen
gerade das ist ja auch jetzt das thema
wer ist das thema wenn ich jetzt nicht
dieses thema hätte die zunehmende
digitalisierung der öffentliche
verwaltung sprechen von elektronische
akte sprechen davon dass wir als
kreisverwaltung in ein paar jahren
wirklich dass kein bürger wenn die
verwaltung laufen muss sondern alles
online machen kann wenn man das jetzt
schon hätten wir gut aber das wird noch
dauern damit heinsberg also bisher habe
ich nach meinen informationen sind es
nur erwachsene wie gesagt also ich kann
aber nicht ausschließen dass da auch
kinder dabei sind
bisher haben wir die erfahrung gemacht
oder zumindest bisher war es so dass
kinder in der regel nicht betroffen sind
davon aber ich musste abwarten heute
abend kriegen wir wohl die ergebnisse
von von den untersuchungen vom
kindergarten rein
also das sprechen mehrere gründe führen
also zum einen denke ich mal
unterbrechen von infektionsketten wenn
man ketten nachverfolgen kann wenn man
weiß welche menschen raum ist angeht
wenn man die zahl von personen hat macht
das sinn
ich denke auch die ersten maßnahmen die
wir getroffen haben absolut sinn gemacht
aber man stellt dann irgendwann fest
dass die betroffene person so eine
vielzahl von veranstaltungen besucht
haben sich so viel im sozialen leben
bewegt haben dass man wenn man da
hingehen würden versuchen würde
alle kontaktpersonen alle möglichen
kontaktpersonen ausfindig zu machen dann
unheimlichen aufwand betreiben muss ja
und die müssen ja noch irgendwie
erreicht werden und dann ist ja die
nächste frage was macht man mit denen
wenn die gar keine symptome haben ich
kann ja auch nicht den halben kreis
heinsberg jetzt darum bitten in
häuslicher quarantäne zu gehen
vorsorglich also irgendwo denkmal
tatsächlich aus die normative kraft des
faktischen irgendwo stößt man da
tatsächlich an grenzen und muss dann
auch bei der an einer steigenden anzahl
von tatsächlich infizierten können sich
vorstellen da potenziert sich ja auch
die möglichkeit von kontakten und von
von dingen die man danach verfolgen
müsste
und ich glaube wir nicht selbst wenn ich
jetzt hier 5000 leute daran setzen würde
das alles nachzuverfolgen muss man sich
ja auch dann die frage stellen was
erreiche damit und was wären die
konsequenzen wenn ich herausfinde dass
jemand kontaktperson ist ich habe ja
gerade auch gesagt wenn wir so vorgehen
würden dann müsste ich wahrscheinlich
meinen eigenen krisenstab schon deshalb
nach hause schicken denn natürlich wir
leben auch als menschen hier als als
mitarbeiter der kreisverwaltung als
landrat mitten im kreis heinsberg und
jeder hat bestimmt mittelbar dass das
können sie sich vorstellen jetzt schon
mal mit jemandem zu tun gehabt der
seinerzeit wieder mit einer
kontaktperson in kontakt war also das
was ist es wichtiger dass der krisenstab
weiter arbeitet oder dass wir jetzt die
sag mal platt gesagt die die richtlinien
des robert koch institutes beachten und
ich glaube die die bürger haben glaube
ich ein anspruch darauf dass die für sie
wichtigen institutionen funktionieren
und arbeiten
nein also die so genannte person 0 das
ist sowohl in fachkreisen so ist das
nach wie vor nicht bekannt
ich bin auch ich zweifel auch daran dass
ich das jemals aufklären lässt wir
wissen nur alle betroffenen also auch
das ehepaar was immer so im fokus steht
müssen sich vor karneval irgendwo
angesteckt haben
und dann sind sie von da aus die ketten
dann weiter gelaufen das zeigt mir aber
auch dass das was wir jetzt erleben
eigentlich hinter den anstieg und
geschichten schon wieder ein bis zwei
wochen hinterher ist das heißt also wenn
wir jetzt werden wir jetzt hier stehen
und darüber sprechen das muss man auch
mal der bevölkerung sagen hat
wahrscheinlich schon wieder eine
vielzahl von menschen nicht nur im kreis
seien schlecht und auch darüber hinaus
das ganze weiter in gang gesetzt ist ja
gerade das typische für eine solche
situation also wir werden wir haben
heute auch mal darüber gesprochen gute
frage wir setzen wir eigentlich am
wochenende was kann man am wochenende
eigentlich an maßnahmen umsetzen wir
werden also auch mit einer etwas
verkleinerten mannschaft hier am
wochenende auch präsent sein um auch
wichtige dinge auch reagieren zu können
ich denke aber auch dass ich ein paar
mitarbeitern mal ein bisschen ruhe
gönnen muss denn auch der fleißigste
mensch muss irgendwann mal eine nacht
durchschlafen ja ja also wir haben ja
die 400 personen die wir ja auch
ermittelt haben plus deren angehöriger
man hochgerechnet sind noch rund 1000
personen
hinzu kommen natürlich die die jetzt
aktuell als infiziert festgestellt
worden sind und die dann in häuslicher
quarantäne gehen soll und sich zu hause
auskurieren sollen wobei auch manche von
denen noch gar keine richtigen symptome
haben also manchmal ein bisschen fieber
mancher grippe aber keiner von denen war
so schwer erkrankt dass ein stationärer
aufenthalt möglich gewesen wäre also bei
aller ernsthaftigkeit der situation muss
man auch immer wieder darauf verweisen
was mir auch wichtig ist zu
transportieren in den allermeisten
fällen nimmt die krankheit einen sehr
glimpflichen verlauf es mag auch sein
dass das schwere fälle bei sind die bei
gott sei dank bis auf die zwei ausnahmen
zur zeit noch nicht haben
also ich will endlich spekulieren also
ich bin ja leiter des krisenstabs
heinsberg ich habe mich heute noch mal
klar positioniert ich halte das sowohl
für unseren staat wie auch für die
menschen für eine maßnahme die sie nicht
akzeptieren werden auch meiner meinung
nach nicht akzeptieren können und ich
weiß auch nicht wie effektiv das sein
soll also wenn wir davon ausgehen dass
das ganze schon über deutschland
ausgerollt ist und wir sozusagen die
spitze des eisberges sind aus welchen
gründen auch immer das mag mit 77
kilometer grenze zu den niederlanden
zusammenhängen das mag damit
zusammenhängen dass wir sehr nah an
ballungszentren sind ich weiß es
letztendlich nicht nur wenn ich mir die
entwicklung der fälle angucke dann gehe
ich davon aus dass der kreis heinsberg
in einer woche nicht der einzige kreis
hier nordrhein-westfalen geschweige denn
in deutschland sein wird der mit einer
vergleichbaren situation zu kämpfen hat
das muss man auch klipp und klar sagen
und was wollen wir denn jetzt absperren
also was soll das dann noch bringen kann
ich noch nicht sagen
trudel meistens so 21 manchmal auch
später eigentlich auch gestern abend
haben wir erst nach 10 uhr die letzte
entwicklung bekommt ihr habt es gibt ja
auch ein bisschen feuer schützen sind
wie damals zu tun anmerkung dass da auch
im möglichen ersten aufgefangen ja also
wie gesagt wir sind ja gerade dabei mal
zu überprüfen ist es nötig dass jede
potenzielle kontaktperson wirklich
erstmal in häuslicher quarantäne geht
das wir werden auch die tests
systematisch etwas anpassen also wir
werden beispielsweise leute die
wichtigen einrichtungen sind und auch
zur verfügung stehen müssen auch um
solche dinge aufrechtzuerhalten
vielleicht auch mal vorrangig testen
wobei wir da wirklich mit dem krisenstab
in ständiger ständiger kommunikation
sind was wir als nächstes machen also es
ist auch immer eine frage was ist
prioritär und was sind erstmal
nebenkriegsschauplätze
ja mir ist das durchaus bewusst dass das
zunehmende belastung für die bevölkerung
wird und wir müssen einfach mal gucken
wie sich jetzt in den nächsten tagen die
fallzahlen entwickelt davon mache ich
eigentlich vieles ab es könnte ja sein
dass wir nicht so einen rasanten anstieg
bekommen dass wir irgendwann auch merken
der krankheitsverlauf und das kann einem
ja im moment auch keiner zuverlässig
sagen also offensichtlich scheint ja
auch hier in deutschland möglicherweise
einiges anders zu sein als in china
beim krankheitsverlauf bei der
behandlung oder wie auch immer also das
mache ich wirklich dann
situationsbedingt davon abhängig wie es
aussieht haben wir uns aber auch
wirklich eng mit dem ministerium
zusammen das ist keine einsame
entscheidung des kreises heinsberg
sondern ich denke man muss ja auch
landesweit man in so einem fall zu einer
gesamtstrategie wenn ich sogar
bundesweit zu einer gesamtstrategie
kommen irgendwann ja wir haben also
letzten acht nummer vielen dank das
ministerium zwei uhr nur meine leute
hier ist er rund um die uhr besetzt
nochmal testmaterial nach bekommen
in nicht unerheblichem umfang so dass
wir zurzeit also mit testmaterial das
heißt also diesen diesen teströhrchen
ausreichend ausgestattet sind wir müssen
aber auch und das sagen wir die
krankenhäuser da sehr vorsichtig sein
mit dem einsatz von solchen dingen weil
die nahtstelle sind nicht nur diejenigen
die tests entnehmen oder den
teströhrchen doch nicht nach stelle sind
laborkapazitäten in nordrhein westfalen
ja also da sagen jetzt auch schon die
labore bitte bitte testet nur dann wenn
es wirklich medizinisch indiziert ist
weil wir natürlich da auch
kapazitätsprobleme haben
der bohrer richten sich immer mehr
darauf ein das stimmt wir steuern nach
aber die jetzigen testverfahren sie
merken ja wenn ich darüber spreche test
läuft dauert der ungefähr zwölf stunden
ist das ergebnis haben dann können sich
auch ungefähr vorstellen jedenfalls bei
den jetzigen test wenn ich auch wenn ich
das dann auch ist nötig wenn man dann
schnell test hätte oder andere
testmöglichkeit werden natürlich sehr
freuen aber ich glaube da auch da wird
auf bundesebene so weit ich weiß mit
hochdruck daran gearbeitet
ja wir wollen eigentlich momenten nur
die testen die symptome zeigen und wo
der hausarzt auch wirklich eine
indikation sieht also wir müssen da hab
ich mal ein bisschen davon runter kommen
das ist jeder sagt ich habe jetzt
symptome ich rufe jetzt entweder den
kreis und ein haushalts anderen ich will
jetzt sofort getestet werden also da
muss man den bürger klipp und klar sagen
dieses anspruchsdenken können wir nicht
verfolgen ich weiß auch von
nachbarkreisen wo die gesundheitsämter
jetzt schon zu laufen weil leute
verlangen getestet zu werden nochmal wir
müssen das ganze nicht nur für den kreis
heinsberg sehen sondern wir müssen dann
auch mit landesweiten ressourcen mal
arbeiten und ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen auch wenn das sage ich mal
ganz klar auch wenn der
bundesgesundheitsminister wohl die
letzten tage mal gesagt hat besser
einmal zu viel testen das einmal zu
wenig da muss ich da ganz klipp und klar
sagen also wir können nicht auf blaue
hinein testen dafür haben wir in
deutschland gar nicht die kapazitäten
also ich kann ihnen das jetzt nicht
quantifizieren wie haben die zusage dass
wir hilfe bekommen und wir reden ja auch
immer über haus erste knappheit und
dergleichen also ich gehe davon aus dass
wir dass wir gute hilfe bekommen ist hat
der gesundheitsminister auch heute noch
mal gesagt aber quantifizieren kann ich
das zurzeit noch nicht
wir kriegen immer mehr e-mails dass
leute sagen wenn sie sich beim arzt
anmelden
dann sagen die man ein wenig in die
praxis kommen was nachvollziehbar ist
auch die ärzte wollen nach hause kommen
ja gut also ich kann jetzt nicht für die
für die für die politik von von
hausärzten sprechen ich habe auch den
eindruck dass das durchaus
unterschiedlich von haushalt zu haushalt
geändert wird das mag aber auch mit den
kapazitäten zusammenhängen die da jetzt
dann jeweils zur zeit gerade zur
verfügung hat also meine idee ist
eigentlich dass wir die zusätzliche
medizinischen kapazitäten die uns
zugesagt sind sprich die zusätzlichen
ärzte auch über die hausarztpraxen
verteilen um einfach da auch die
expertise zu stärken dass sie einfach
mehr leute durch lesen können oder
beziehungsweise auch hausbesuche
übergehen was bei infizierten oder
möglicherweise infizierten personen
vielleicht sogar noch sinnvoller ist
weil ich sage mal wenn sie eine
kontaktperson haben dann müssen sie eine
kontaktperson schützen wenn jemand in
einer praxis rein läuft da sitzt er dann
am empfang jemand dann ist da noch die
arzthelferin ist ja noch der arzt
vielleicht auch noch eine zweite
arzthelferin und dann stellt sich auch
noch die frage wie das infizieren sie
nachher oder zwischendurch einmal die
räume also es gibt schon praktische
probleme die da auftreten
aber ich denke mal mir ist nicht
jedenfalls nicht bekannt dass einer der
wirklich lebensbedrohlich erkrankt ist
bisher kein arzttermin bekommen hätte
also wir müssen auch ich muss auch die
bevölkerung bitten da ein bisschen
geduld zu haben wir vergessen manchmal
bei so einer geschichte das ja auch
nicht nur dass carola virus
lebensbedrohlich ist sondern dass
kliniken und hausärzte mit einer
vielzahl von weiteren lebensbedrohlichen
erkrankungen tagtäglich umgehen müssen
und ich kann jetzt auch nicht für den
einzelnen sprechen der an ort und stelle
beurteilen muss was ist jetzt prioritär
was mache ich jetzt zuerst dass das kann
auch durchaus ganz unterschiedlich sein
und ich gehe davon aus jeder hausarzt
hat ein interesse daran dass hier im
kreis heinsberg die ganzen dinge
möglichst glimpflich verlaufen und das
haben wir heute die vertreter der
kassenärztliche vereinigung die die
hausärzte vertreter nochmal zugesichert
also ich sag ja noch mal ich habe heute
ganz klipp und klar über facebook gesagt
solange ich hier was im kreis heinsberg
zu sagen habt gibt es ja keine
sperrungen
ja und wenn sie dann das feedback
bekommen dann wissen sie auch dass die
leute mir vertrauen und dieses vertrauen
werde ich nicht missbrauchen